hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video spective with this I thought I'd
do a little bit of a full-face game
because in the last time we did one of
these passionate videos a lot of you
said that you actually thoroughly
enjoyed me going through and showing the
patches from the website as it just
opposed to talking and showing gameplay
so that's the way we're doing it now I
also thought I'd change it up with a
full face cam so yeah we got a lot of
interesting stuff to talk about it's
patch 2.4 teens coming out on October
10th which if you're watching this the
day that's going live it should be out
tomorrow but it's you know the upcoming
Thursday but a lot of stuff with a
gladiator change very confusing yeah I
like to do if you do any like I
subscribe for you know let's get started
see as I stated we're gonna be going
over a patch 2.14 like I said this would
be going live on all platforms tomorrow
on October 10th roughly around 9 a.m. ET
or Eastern Standard Time so pretty early
in the morning tomorrow the downtime
will be expected to be about thirty
minutes so if you are gonna be up when
this is going live just be aware I might
be going for about thirty minutes
yeah so I've kind of briefly read
through these patch notes and some of
the stuff we already know but the main
improvement was actually gladiator now
remember this is going live tomorrow
which is the confusing thing which I'll
get a little bit more into so for
gladiator for his improvements he got an
increased guard duration of 1100
milliseconds it used to be 600 that's
always cool his light attack speed also
got increased the second third and
fourth chained lights and from the top
are going to be 433 milliseconds and the
second third and fourth chain lights
from the side are going to be 500 as
opposed to six on it so really cool
there on top of that the toast AB was
decreased to 600 milliseconds went out
of stamina these used to be 800 and then
the miss recovery is now 700 as opposed
to 1,000 they decreased and unified all
fou shiness ectis miss recovery to
recover the guard at 600 m/s into the
Miss which was 700 to 1000 a lot of
jumbled up words everything at the point
and for skewered they wanted to forward
movement for the skewer during the
strike and the feint now these in
general have been things that we already
know about this is gladiators rework and
it doesn't really make any sense why
this is coming out now when this should
be with the season 12 release and
there's actually a lot more that they're
going to be adding so if you come down
here it says developer comments we want
to give gladiator faster tools to
improve his won
abilities accelerating the lights out of
stamina toast that ball that stuff we
know about but they actually changed a
bit more things they stated that his
increased sprint attack forward movement
is going to be six meters as the boost
the three point five and his sprint
speed is now seven point two five meters
per second as opposed to 6.5 and
bamboozle Nawal splats which is really
interesting and as they stated here as
an assassin we want gladiator to be more
efficient at rotating and capping points
as well as chasing fleeing opponents and
they also stated that the bamboozle is
very highly situational so we added this
property to make it useful for more than
just legend scenarios which I'm totally
cool with we're gonna talk a little bit
about my thoughts on why this is being
released tomorrow but later in the video
but first I want to continue through the
rest of this and there really isn't much
left that was the main majority warlord
is the last part and a warlord light
attacks are now enhanced warlords light
attack openers now have slightly
increased range they increased this top
light attack opener to 18 slide blood
attack openers to 15 decreased the top
blade finishers to 18 and they kept his
top light finisher to medium hit
reaction which will stole a lot legend
like before his heavy attack a super
armor and now starts at 300 as opposed
to 400 and adjusting the tracking on his
stab from full block stance and once
again as you're noticing this is also
from his rework maybe they changed I
believe maybe a couple things I'm
unaware if this was the full exact one
but it is basically exactly what like
what the developers had stated so what
leads but this leads me to believe is
that either
gladiator and warlord are not getting
reworks for season 12 and they were just
getting it released early which I'm
pretty sure is definitely not the case
but I'm thinking that from all the
feedback that they got from the new
stuff from the testing grounds that
gladiator is going to be getting a whole
new rework because they still promised
that in season 12 gladiator would get a
rework along with Centurion getting the
biggest one and warlord or getting the
smallest one with gladiator getting the
medium so if they're gonna be releasing
this now which on October 10th which is
probably like a month before the actual
season 12 releases that doesn't really
count as the season 12 rework that's
just the season 11 midseason rework
which really makes no sense at all
so I think that
basically what they're gonna do is give
gladiator this stuff and now and then
they're going to buff a lot more things
in the future I'm thinking they're gonna
buff the buckler punch maybe as hyper
armor hit zone or maybe not so much as
buff those but definitely change
something regarding those that's my
interpretation that's it that's what I
think that's the thing that makes the
most sense to me at least I don't really
see any other idea for this it's just
very confusing because it just doesn't
make a whole lot of sense why they would
release this tomorrow as opposed to
waiting a month but that's just my
opinion let me know what you guys think
about this stuff in the comments down
below
after reading actually some of the
comments from down here from this post
it is seeming like a lot of people are
in the general consensus that this is
still the season 12 rework but they're
just getting released a lot earlier than
anticipated I'm still holding hope that
this is the up this is just a change for
them and that they'll get even more
changes come the beginning of the season
I maybe just be grasping at a few things
I'm a little bit eager to get more
changes for GLAAD because in my opinion
as much as I like glads current rework I
still feel like there was a lot of
things that could have done to him but
that's just me anyway guys that's gonna
be the end of it today let me know what
you guys think about the stuff in the
comments below let me know if you guys
think this is there's gonna be more
changes in the future or they're just
happening to release the rework for
these two characters early and then
Centurion comes when the actual season
releases and we like the V if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the Patrick's of the leaks if
you wanna be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update they subscribe the channel bye
guys take care have a girl's today let
me know in the comments below what you
think peace out
you